[Music]  it look like you guys are so much closer  this season yes we are just loving each  other and having a blast you know  there's so many ups and downs you know  everything about each other  this is coming around a couple years we  just got closer and we really support  each other in everything we do United  States versus the situation dude prisons  no joke it's scary  we really are that close we really do  have this awesome group chat yeah we  speak every day what was the last thing  in their check beside to build what a  consideration for that me yeah okay I  want to talk to you about this this is  amazing guys might be nominated for what  do you think I think that when we did it  first time of that category be honest is  that why you wanted to do this for me  we were like this like eight Guido's  from you know the Jersey area we'll  never expected to be in the conversation  of so really it's so dope to be in  consideration  [Music]  [Applause]